okay so just this straight it isn't it
doesn't look it really does not look
straight then again apparently neither
do we so so we had a chat in the office
a couple of weeks ago I mean okay we
have today as well but I'm talking about
a specific chat we okay specifically
where we were looking at code like this
so right we go you're all script you
tagged see a script you tagged always
good
pull the variables in there mm-hm a VAR
Const I call and again but but this time
it's a module all right and then the
question we were posing each other it
was like well what what what can be
accessed what is available in the third
script tag which in this case is a
module tack exact a now the only reason
it's the module tag right okay you're
now making me go on a tangent already
the only reason it's a module you're
welcome
is because if it was normal script tag
these would not run in this order Oh
because modules are deferred by
implicitly yes so if if it was a script
tag with defer what is it's ignored all
because it's in line yet the first
ignored on inline script yes it is today
you learned there we go oh good tangent
now the way yes the only reason I put
type module on this is a good order so
they actually execute an order they
appear on the snippet right exactly
good so you're actually just a Twitter
poll if you did a Twitter poll it was no
I did not look like this exactly but
related very similar
yes so some of the same things and we
followed yeah like I wanted to write it
I wanted to tweet this so I did a poll
24 hours wanted to tweet the solution no
no you don't best precious content and
again this time we actually have played
semi good content exactly exact amounts
decide if this is actually the comments
decide made oh okay
I think I'd like let's start by talking
about how scoping works in JavaScript
yeah I mean that's what this all about
exactly okay but we'll go back to the
start so back in olden times ye all D
JavaScript T this is like he is three
yes three time the only way you could
create a variable was with var yes and
which is good because that sort of a
stands for a variable it is but you
could also create functions yeah that
was in the s3 as well yeah we had those
but they behaved in very very similar
ways
so a var or a function would be scoped
to the parent function mm-hmm or the
global if there wasn't one okay so here
we got one and as a you two boundaries
that they existed at the time I did a
function or you had the global hold onto
that oh boy or girl boy okay so we've
got yes var one there is on the global
mmm-hmm two on the global mmm-hmm
function so it scoped to the function
and 4 is also scoped to it within two so
you couldn't call for out of here it's
that wouldn't work yeah so if you did
something like this if you did VAR v
inside a an if ya and of function six
they would actually now exist in within
to within to be able to log them because
blocksberg not a scoping mechanism so
you could naively say that the only
thing that has a scope in javascript in
this era was a function that's what I
would have is what you would have said
there are two cases where that was not
true
and still it isn't true okay so and so I
will give you a clue there's like these
are not places that you can create
variables as such but there are places
where an identifier has a scope which is
smaller than a function oh that's oddly
the phrasing was so oddly specific well
I'm trying to help I love like putting
you on the spot I do this a lot of new
videos and it's stuff that I wouldn't
get either technically what about for
loops go back if I had to for VAR i
equals 0 is that i available after the
for loop yes it is so that would go up
into the parent scope and we've we've
done a video about
wasn't constant right and so I wasn't
sure if that was also some weirdness no
oh this is gonna be a short video but I
think we now we should just sit here and
say hey Devin its helm a very construct
in es3 should I just tell you because I
wouldn't have got this either go on
there
catch the errors right in olden days as
well thank you very much
but this error identifier is only
available in the catch interesting okay
and I saw this but I didn't know all
right
why a new catch had a scope associated
with it but actually because I'd heard
that it misled me to think that
variables would be scoped within it
they're not usable in here those again
would bubble up to the yosef function or
scope well but the error is stays within
the catch block okay and the other one
which I ought forgive you for not
knowing it's with that sort of thing
well it wasn't yes three is it still a
thing I think in strict mode it stops
you using it but don't hold me to that
what does with even do right what it
will do is it will just like a
replacement for scope block a block
scope well so it will take all of the
properties of object and create local
variables for them inside the website
the whiffed lock so it is I believe and
again don't hold me to this I believe
it's the only thing in JavaScript where
the the variables that can exist within
it and not deterministic like you can't
just do it apart you can't figure that
out at past time I guess the other part
is eval and they're about and that's why
both of these things like if you're
using eval if you use with a lot of the
performance optimizations that engines
have just go out the window yeah cuz
they can't the fact that sometimes I got
this you know means that it's it's a
thing it is a thing is having so that's
the two things I have a different scope
I am but then right oh yes special
behavior special magic behavior oh boy
oh the hosting no this is not hosting
the hosting is there's going to be a
short video
no I'm not gonna talk about hosting
people can search with hosting once fine
good all my favorite word's hoisting
least hosting source if you have a
global variable with var or function
mm-hmm it does a magic thing in that it
will also well it will put it on the
global object house of magic huh that's
the thing that is on that it's the
global array well you say that but there
something cuz you're used to it right
it's actually weird
come on this we're sweet but other
sucessfully the whole premise of
JavaScript you have this that your
global scope is also tied to a specific
identifier but maybe that's just me
coming into JavaScript too late where
all these things have already been
figured out well hold on to that I would
say just a side yep so self is referring
to that the global object that's what it
is in the browser yeah you also have
window that's only in Windows if you're
currently talking history right because
this is already different your global
object is itself today your global
object is window if you're in a document
global is the global in node and the new
bit is global this which is trying to
standardize across all of those because
it turns out we couldn't standardize on
any one of these because people use it
to did it was a case where self and
window might not be equal maybe I'm
wrong that's not that's not that's not
that's not I definitely don't know if
it's off my head ok so yes so this is
the magic case it's me it's weird and
magic that it let stuff in the global
still a window yes in mario script tags
yes ok Damron got much I though we got
some new stuff we got new stuff new
JavaScript stuff arrived along with var
we got some new ones constant that we've
talked about on the show before and
these have more sensible scoping should
we say more yeah less unorthodox it
specifically block level scoping so
inside this if as we've already seen one
is going to be thrown into the parent
scope a function or a global where it's
two will only exist inside a vlog and
same with three mm-hm and I true for
while for
any color braces right in fact you can
do that
ah that's a figure and there you go and
it works so that's kind of how you think
about it if it's got the curly braces
two and three are going to do the right
thing inside there so ever I was playing
around and it suddenly occurred to me
yeah
what's gonna happen now this should not
throw this short I think this will work
what do you think will happen because
the var1 will bubble up to the
containing scope wouldn't be the
function of the global scope and then
the const one will shadow that because
chattering it's a thing anyway
yeah no oh that is no what happens i
genuinely when i fall about this i
didn't know and i agree with you like
runtime this could be a thing but it
fails at past time it sees to identify
as being declared in the same scope even
though if I will do something it's like
really and it's like what if you throw
yes yes first thing and I guess it might
be down to that if you have Const one in
a block yeah you cannot previous to that
refer to one in a parent scope it will
tell you you are trying to use the thing
before it is declared so I think that's
where this comes I see but if I move the
VAR outside the curly braces it's like a
giant right that's interesting yeah so
there we go
that's there was a pointless piece of
information but it's something I learned
while making the slides for this so I
guess the first part of the question
really is we've got we've kind of seen
these VARs we've seen these constants
things but across to script tags how
does how does they work how oh yeah how
does it how does they work one goes onto
the global as we've seen yeah we're
pretty sure about one at this point it
works
- it's already slightly yes so you can
also do self that one fair enough and
yes the questionable one is - that was a
good sentence to say wasn't one is too
questionable the one that is
questionable is - now there's no good
way of saying that do you know what I
went to back and forth on the variable
naming here who's been just doing a B C
and D or one two three or four and I
felt like I'd done the right thing now
I realize I didn't know okay it's very
confusing well it's better than fubar
but so that's what I started with and I
ran out people yo I mean that is this
close and oh I don't remember I don't
remember after that it's Ashley useless
tangent so um - the thing is I did the
quiz I looked at the solution I don't
remember really great excellent so when
you do want to at the top level like far
it goes on the global scope it goes in
the globe okay cool so this works cuz
the two scripts share a global scope
mm-hmm contrary to what I think most
people on Twitter believed a script tag
is not equivalent with like curly braces
it's not scope exactly correct but this
is where things get different right yes
I remember now and this is so yes it too
does go on the global in terms of the
Ekman script it is a global but what it
doesn't do is it doesn't do the weird
you know running it into the global
object because technically the global
object is under the actual global
context it seems like that's how I
understood yang one of our v8 engineers
who wrote an explanation yes yes and
sort of in some ways the the global that
one and two exists on are the same in
some ways they are in some ways they
aren't because same again like if you
did var one equals trillion var Const 1
equals true like you can think if
they're if they're sitting a different
level it should all be fine but it's not
it will stop you from doing that's on
one global right except I guess then
that that actually is magic like you
said that the one gets additionally
patched into the global object which is
something else from the global context
yes this kind of objects record fan in a
coma script and that's how that's how
that works so yes so there we go one
works self dot one works
two works self dot 2 will be undefined
probably undefined so there we go okay
but what happens here
what changes well I did know that's
module scripts
don't bubble up to the global you're
sort of right the if you create its
imagine that they're wrapped in a
function right right so they just have a
free-floating var in a script module tag
that will not end up on the global
context or the global object correct so
it will you still have access to the
global but you saw access document and
you want to put something on the global
you have to do it manually and
explicitly absolutely right that is true
so that I guess takes us to to this
request e on the quest the quest T on
misty on from how to teach you is to say
question on Easter why it's just wrong
isn't it and you know what as a teacher
you say that word a lot so it's really
frustrating this question all right so
we know now that one m2 will be that
well
oh no right now let's do the rest of the
episode without actually saying proper
words so why don't two are on the global
context the global context so but know
these the lookups also happen on the
global context so this will work so no
one works cell for that one what works
self the two will be undefined sub dot
so will be undefined for the reasons we
did before because it's even though it's
in a script module it accesses it in the
usual way that will throw that's will
absolutely fro yes I supposed to
remember yes because we treat module as
if it's wrapped in a function it's got
its own kind of an undeclared variable
undeclared variables off dot three would
be still undefined because that's
different that doesn't throw looking up
and and a property is fine
yeah so the undefined that wouldn't
throw for same would also from yeah and
as it that is how scopes work in
JavaScript I mean you say like there now
you understood all the patterns like if
if you rely I only care if you rely on
variables being passed in between script
tags implicitly
probably well in at that pattern there
are cases you would do this because like
if you've got a
like you're doing a server render thing
but you also want to dump the initial
set of data into a spray tag that is
someone where you will work to do I'm
saying that if you want to do that
make it as Clifford write self blah blah
blah Oh interesting yeah okay stop
you're liking these implicit rules
because then everybody will look at this
and have to oh I don't remember how the
details were of these global contact
scoping rules I will I would actually
agree with that I think the whole thing
about well there's a reason why
constitute doesn't end up on the global
object because it's weird and all right
we have want to stop the putting
everything in the global object right
because it's even kind of polluted over
time anyway yeah so let's only make that
happen when it's a conscious choice by
the developer to actually write down
self dot equals yeah fine
and that's and we do see that with
future JavaScript as well things like
async functions generators all of that
they're functions they still behave like
functions but class behaves more like
constant let yeah and that it will be
like a block scoped and not do the
global it's something I looked up on the
train this morning thinking so am I
asked that so I bet you didn't ask that
so I just fought crowbar looking back
then so I feel like fulfilled right did
you use all your knowledge you looked up
now something else you want to sprinkle
in that is all the knowledge I had to
give you in this episode done thank you
very much for this insightful report pan
gotten used to wearing my glasses for
this shoot and now I'm gonna get what
point I can confidently pull up the
rustle and go like that well that's
right no it's actually with I've got
cuz I wear glasses it yeah you have
they're the they've got to but they're
saying the stripes of doom no really
my advices are actually really harsh
like that button and so I've been
thinking like if I just keep wearing
them and it's get better